PLANNING A MASSACRE BUT NEVER
FOLLOWED UP ON THAT.
IF SOME ONE HAD TOLD THEM CRUZ
WAS TALKING TO VLADIMIR PUTIN
THEY WOULD HAVE BEEN ON IT.
JONATHAN TURLEY JOINS US
TONIGHT.
FACEBOOK TROLLS?
I MEAN I'M NOT FOR THAT BUT I'M
A LITTLE DISAPOINTED THAT
APPEARS TO BE THE SUM TOTAL OF
THIS.
>> IT IS AMAZING, ISN'T IT.
YOU WONDER WHETHER PUTIN IS IN
MOSCOW WATCHING THE WOMEN'S
MARCH AND SAYING THOSE 12 GUYS
DID A LOT.
YOU DIDN'T HAVE TO SEND THEM TO
THE UNITED STATES TO DI VOID US
POLITICALLY.
THAT WAS -- DIVIDE US
ALSO AMAZING HOW GRATUITOUS THIS
IS.
AFTER THE ELECTION THEY START
PULLING PROTESTS ON OPPOSING
SIDES.
STRIKING HOW LITTLE REALLY COULD
HAVE BEEN ACCOMPLISHED BY THIS.
AT THE END OF THE DAY THE MOST
INTERESTING THING IS THE
ADJECTIVE, UNWITTING.
AFTER THE YEAR, AFTER THE PLEA
AGREEMENTS, AFTER ALL OF THESE
INTERVIEWS THEY REALLY DON'T
HAVE ANY EVIDENCE OF ANYONE
KNOWINGLY ENGAGING WITH
RUSSIANS.
NOT EVEN MENTIONING THE TRUMP
POWER MEETING WHERE THEY KNEW
THEY WERE RUSSIANS.
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE ANY THERE
THERE.
>> Tucker: GETTING CLOSE TO 20
INDICTMENTS AND NONE OF THEM
SPEAK DIRECTLY TO THE UNDERLYING
CHARGES.
THEY'RE PERJURY, MONEY
LAUNDERING, FAILURE TO REGISTER
AS A FOREIGN AGENT, I MEAN I'M
NOT SAYING THEY'RE INSIGNIFICANT
BUT SKIRTING THE EDGE OF
INSIGNIFICANT.
ARE WE GOING TO GET ACTUAL
CHARGES AGAINST ANYBODY, WOULD
YOU SAY?
>> WELL THAT IS WHAT ALSO
STRIKING ABOUT THIS.
THE CHARGES THEMSELVES ARE
ACTUALLY QUITE CONVENTIONAL.
THINGS LIKE IDENTITY THEFT,
WHICH IS VERY COMMON WITH
RUSSIAN ASSOCIATIONS.
HACKING.
WHAT ISN'T CONVENTIONAL IS THE
CONTEXT.
THIS IS ONE OF THE LARGEST
INDICTMENTS FOR TRYING TO
INTERFERE WITH AN ELECTION.
IT JUST THAT THE EVIDENCE MUCH
ANY SUCCESS IN THAT IS MINIMAL.
PEOPLE HAVE CRITICIZED
ROSENSTEIN FOR SAYING THERE WAS
NO EVIDENCE OF THIS IMPACTING
THE ELECTION.
BUT I THINK THAT WHAT HE WAS
SAYING WAS THIS, WE HAVEN'T
REALLY FOUND ANYTHING QUITE
SIGNIFICANT IN THESE ACTIVITIES.
NOW, HAVING SAID THAT, WE SHOULD